in november johnson and johnson and
general electric both announced that
they are splitting up
johnson and johnson will break into two
separate public companies one focused on
consumer health products and the other
on pharmaceuticals and ge will split
into three companies centered on
healthcare power and aviation
the splintering of these two
heavyweights is just the latest in a
number of big corporate breakups even as
tech companies continue to consolidate a
lot of people are saying that this may
be the end or the death of the corporate
conglomerate as we've known it here's
what led to the latest wave of breakups
and what they could mean for legions of
shareholders with a stake in these
industry titans
the breakup of conglomerates isn't a new
phenomenon the rationale for industrial
conglomerates in the first place was
efficiency jason zweig has been covering
investing and financial history for the
wall street journal for over a decade he
says the conglomerate model tended to
work for a while until the market got
overheated it stopped working and people
learned that these businesses rise and
fall together one of the things that
happened in the 1980s is that we had the
rise of the leverage buyout movement
which today we would call private equity
and so large funds were able to get
access to relatively cheap money which
they could use to buy undervalued asset
so a lot of conglomerates chose that
particular time
to split up conglomerates continued to
decline in popularity in the 1990s and
2000s and then in 2008 this happened the
dow tumbled more than 500 points after
two pillars of the street tumbled over
the weekend the 2008 financial crisis
marked a new shift for some of the
remaining industrial conglomerates
investors led a push to break up bigger
companies when the individual units seem
to be underperforming independent rivals
for example siemens the german
multinational technology giant saw its
stock plunge more than 60 percent under
pressure from investors it shed its
healthcare and energy businesses
shifting from a conglomerate into a
company focused on higher margin
software and technology this strategy
worked since then siemens market
capitalization has surpassed its rival
ge
for years ge one of america's oldest
industrial giants had been struggling
the company was engaging in some
aggressive accounting in the late 90s
and into into the beginning of the 2000s
um you know that led to problems down
the road
ge capital its financial arm was taking
risks that really did not
pan out during the financial crisis and
like siemens ge faced pressure both
internally and externally to split after
parts of its business continued to
perform poorly certainly management was
under enormous pressure internally to do
something meanwhile they were under
enormous pressure from
activists institutional investors
in the early 2000s ge began selling off
portions of its business from insurance
and appliances to nbc universal general
electric is selling nbc universal to the
cable tv giant comcast and its majority
stake in oil and gas and on november 9
2021 the company announced it would
break up its last three parts marking
the end of an era for the industrial
titan this was just days before johnson
and johnson the world's largest health
products company by sales announced
plans to break up as well but it had
different reasons johnson and johnson's
ceo said the company decided to split
because the businesses customers and
markets have diverged so much in recent
years a pattern that accelerated during
the pandemic i think they just reached
the point where like ge they felt they
could be more efficient and
each unit could get the full attention
it deserved if they split part
zweig says that when conglomerates split
it's often due to external pressure when
things start to go wrong what people say
is
you could realize the value that's
locked up
in these parts of the company so people
will go from viewing it as a unified
whole
to viewing it as a set of pieces that
would do better when they were broken
off from the whole
and that applies to institutional
investors individual investors
competitors an executive at johnson and
johnson said it will be in a better
position standing alone to make
decisions and allocate resources
so what do big corporate breakups mean
for shareholders over the long run
split ups do tend to
create value for
investors in in the surviving companies
now whether it'll be true in these
particular cases is
very difficult to say for johnson and
johnson investors can expect the second
company will have a new name and the
legacy business will continue to go by j
j
for ge current shareholders are likely
to receive shares of the new energy and
healthcare companies as dividends when
they spin off while the original company
that remains will focus on aviation this
may be the end or it might just be the
end of the beginning
but
it's likely that
we will see more of these breakups for
many non-tech companies the future is
looking smaller and more specialized but
what it means for investors is yet to be
seen
[Music]
you